Welcome to Module Five — semantic segmentation.
Here we go from labeling a whole image to predicting a class for every single pixel.
We'll cover encoder–decoder architectures, losses for imbalance, and post-processing.
The bridge from classification is the fully convolutional network.
Take any CNN classifier, swap its dense layers for one-by-one convolutions, and upsample the feature maps back to the input resolution.
FCN-32s, 16s, and 8s just fuse skip connections more and more finely, and the output is a tensor of height, width, and number of classes.
The workhorse is the U-Net — a symmetric encoder and decoder joined by skip connections.
Those skips carry fine spatial detail across the bottleneck, which is why U-Net trains well even on very small medical datasets.
Attention U-Net, TransUNet, and the self-configuring nnU-Net are its modern descendants.
For richer context there's DeepLab.
Atrous, or dilated, convolutions expand the receptive field without throwing away resolution to pooling.
Stack several of them in parallel at different rates and you get ASPP, the heart of DeepLabv3+, which sits at the state of the art on Cityscapes and Pascal VOC.
Your loss choice is where imbalance is won or lost.
Plain cross-entropy is sensitive to it.
Dice loss optimizes overlap directly.
Focal loss down-weights the easy pixels, and Tversky lets you trade false positives against false negatives.
In practice, combining cross-entropy with Dice often wins.
And a little post-processing goes a long way: a dense CRF sharpens boundaries, morphological operations clear small noise, test-time augmentation averages flips and rotations, and ensembling backbones buys you another point or two of mean IoU.
Let's build a U-Net from scratch — open the labs.